the North Korean leader Kim Jong-un has
visited Russia's warplanes and naval
fleet in the Far Eastern Port City of
Vladivostok he was joined by the Russian
defense minister Sergey shoigu the visit
has raised concerns that North Korea may
provide Russia with weapons for its war
in Ukraine Florence Louis is following
the visit from South Korea's capital
Seoul
the Korean leader Kim jong-un's visit to
Russia rolls into its fifth day on
Saturday he was met by defense minister
Sergey shoigu at an Air Force Base where
he was shown nuclear-capable bombers and
Hypersonic missiles
it can fly from Moscow to Japan and then
back it carries 12 missiles this was
followed by a tour of a naval base where
he inspected Russia's Pacific Fleet it
may be no coincidence that Kim's
itinerary has consisted mostly of visits
to defense and Military facilities
the North Korean leader has spoken
frequently of his intention to modernize
his country's Fleet of aircraft ships
and submarines
while some analysts are skeptical Russia
would part with highly sensitive
technology others say the war in Ukraine
has given North Korea the upper hand in
negotiations there are concerns
particularly here in South Korea that a
more powerful Pyongyang could accelerate
an arms race and further destabilize the
region the Kremlin says no defense
agreement has been signed during Kim's
visit but the White House believes a
weapons deal is in the works and has
warned the two countries not to violate
U.N sanctions our view has been before
the visit
and after the visit that talks about the
provision of weapons by North Korea to
Russia to kill ukrainians have been
advancing and continue to advance in
North Korea Kim's visit has received
widespread coverage
respected comrade Kim Jong-un visits
Yuri Gagarin Aviation plant respected
comrade Kim Jong-un expressed respect
for Russia's fast developing aviation
technology that allows it to outpace
potential threats from other countries
perhaps an intention to communicate with
a domestic audience that North Korea is
a powerful Nation with important allies
and Russia's warm welcome of Kim has
left no doubt that these countries
intend to build stronger ties
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Seoul
for more on this let's go to Daniel
Hawkins who's standing by for us in
Moscow Daniel is it safe to assume as
the U.S has done that this trip paves
the way for some kind of military
cooperation between Russia and North
Korea
well certainly an increase in
cooperation in the defense sector has
been pretty much admitted by top
officials but really this visit has been
about sending a very keen message to the
West a very strong message and to grab
the West attention which is done these
very carefully drifted images of Kim
Jong-un visiting military facilities the
Navy uh the aerodrome is designed to
show that Russia and North Korea are
upgrading their relations not only in
the military sphere but across multiple
other spheres mentioned by Vladimir
Putin and they certainly have got the
West attention through These Warnings by
the west and its allies for North Korea
and Russia not to engage in an armors
deal not to break International
sanctions and really um it's important
for Russia as part of this deal to have
an ally and a partner in the
asia-pacific region which uses a very
key strategic area of competition with
the United States
um the U.S of course views North Korea
as part of this so-called axis of Evil
for Russia North Korea he's a partner in
an axis of resistance against U.S
hegemony and dominance what it perceives
to be U.S expansionism in terms of an
arms deal of course yes there is much
speculation involved in this but this
whatever agreement was reached behind
closed doors is going to be very much
shrouded in secrecy as is this whole
visit because of course both countries
will be Keen to avoid the consequences
of anything uh leaking anything going
public North Korea wanting to avoid
extra sanctions Russia which has called
on states to observe international law
will want to avoid compromising that
position
analysts have said will any uh Munitions
from North Korea which are Old Reliable
be a game changer in Ukraine it's
unlikely to be so so for Russia perhaps
the possibility and the threat of such a
deal
in the eyes of the West is much more
important as leverage and a bargaining
ship for any possible future
negotiations on other geopolitical
Global issues Daniel Hawkins thanks for
that reporting from Moscow